opening day of yet another area 15
experience now whether it's date night
family time or
you just love art you can immerse
yourself into the world of vincent van
gogh like never before
here's rocky with a preview
you know area 15 is all about the
immersive experiences
so this is this is not just going to say
van gogh kingston
museum this is actually you feel like
they're in the mind of van gaalin
that was a very complicated one yes
that's true this is the van gogh
immersive experience
at area 15. this is incredible what can
people enjoy
a lot of his people yes 300 of his
paintings brought to life with 21st
century technology that literally put
you into a 19th century masterpiece
and it's here at area 15 in the portal
it's the first time it's ever happened
in america
so this has been shown all over the
world yes it's right it's the first time
here in our country
right here in las vegas i love that now
i hear
the voice of vincent van gogh and his
letters to his brother theo which were
just poignant and beautiful in and of
what are themselves actually learning
well we're thinking they get to a
plaintiff transformation and you come
with uh not a demographic a
psychographic i love that and
you have mentioned that because you're
so proud of the diverse group you have
enjoying we have all shapes and sizes
all every you know it's not for everyone
but everybody's welcome
okay so introduce us to your guests that
you that you are so well i mean
they just popped in the door today here
they are um i
just met them today we have karen and
uh and alice and uh they tell us that
they're fans of area 15 and that they
came to this show
but they you were here for the opening
of meow wolf as well
what do you think of it today this is
the most
incredible amazing surreal experience
i've ever had in a museum
i i'm just blown away by this and
if i have one thing to say you have to
come back
a second time because it moves so fast
that you don't have an opportunity to
read all the writing that you've got
on the wall all the sayings that mean
a lot anyway thank you for this amazing
experience
thank you and and last but not least
here i just want you to invite people
down to come
see please come and see this it is so
amazing you can't
understand it till you see it and then
you still can't understand it it is an
amazing
amazing thing there you have it
everybody come down area 15.com for
tickets
this is beautiful i could stay here all
day i'll send it back to you
all right thank you rocky that is i mean
that's a cool place and did you know
van gogh painted almost 900 paintings in
less than 10 years
wow and he only sold one in his entire
lifetime i hear that rocky's gonna have
a few more fun facts about van gogh
coming up
in the four o'clock newscast